effectivement et ça discute déjà
beaucoup sur le plateau de la voie est
libre on parle donc de la réforme du
code du travail avec sandrine moins pour
la cgt de marc ayrault pour fo monsieur
pierre antoine kern pour le medef et
yves barbe pour lui paie a alors le
gouvernement veut aller vite il l'a dit
pour cette réforme les mesures proposées
par myriam el khomri seront donc annoncé
ce mercredi et dès lors va commencer la
deuxième phase de concertation vous y
participerez tous
oui et alors dans qu'est ce que vous
amènerez sur sur la table alors je
voudrais quand même revenir ont pris un
à lille même mois attention ça se passe
très faisable a très vite je le dis
c'est que le medef pas part du postulat
que les droits des salariés la
protection du sérail c'est un coût pour
l'entreprise et c'est préjudiciable à
l'emploi
ça veut dire que voilà les salariés qui
ont des droits
c'est contraire à l'emploi c'est ça qui
nous interpelle donc pour nous on
conteste pas la complexité du code du
travail
ceci étant on renvoie à la complexité du
code du commerce donc sa régie vos
entreprises également des codes mais
effectivement il faut déjà faire une
évaluation des droits des salariés
comme on l'a déjà mis en pré ans on a vu
qu'il ya de multiples dérogations pour
nous ce qu'il faut c'est prendre en
compte l'évolution du salariat comme on
l'a déjà dit les salariés au forfait
jours
le télétravail ces salariés qui sont à
la limite entre le salariat et
effectivement les indépendants vous
savez les fameuses hubert où on voit
déjà que les salariés qui se rebellent a
quand même un tout le principe de la
sous traitance donc une évaluation
prendre en compte cette évolution du
salariat pour une chose c'est à dire
qu'il faut des droits des salariés issus
de la loi du code du travail qui
garantissent des droits à tous les
salariés petites entreprises pme grands
groupes sous traitants et que ensuite il
y ait des négociations de branche ou on
peut revoir l'ensemble des branches et
mener des négociations d'entreprise mais
qu' elles ne peuvent qu'améliorer la loi
parce que la loi c'est le garant de
l'intérêt général pour tous les salariés
ce caire quelles sont vos attentes vous
à des attentes
elles sont celles que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure à savoir effectivement les
inversions de là
y'a rachid et d'adhésion alors j'ai peur
de faire peur avec ce terme et même
aider mais du coup vous avez déjà perdu
non non non non je crois qu'il ya aucun
combat qu'ils ne soient perdues d'avancé
puis nécessité fait loi je dire tant
qu'on aura ses mauvais résultats
économiques
il faudra bien se poser les bonnes
questions se dire comment trouver des
solutions pour remédier à cela
je crois que la véritable injustice
aujourd'hui elle serait pas qu'un
salarié atteint un peu moins de droit à
lille qu'à marseille
la véritable injustice et qu' il ya
plein de gens qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
de travail
et c'est cette injustice là qu'il faut
arriver à résoudre si on veut une
société équilibrée et puis pour cela il
faut permettre à l'économie de se
déployer et d'être en mesure de
combattre
quant à concurrence vous oubliez
toujours la concurrence dans vos propos
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que les
concurrents étrangers n'existe pas pour
vous cette extraordinaire quand même
sauf ardeurs du nom c'est le cognac
lysiens et c'est le quotidien des chefs
d'entreprise et pour se battre à armes
égales
il faut que nous ayons davantage de
souplesse donc plus on pourra décider au
plus près de l'entreprise mieux ce sera
moi je vous donne un exemple quand je
signe un accord d'intéressement avec mes
salariés c'est un accord qui se discute
j'allais dire c'est de la démocratie
participative c'est démocratie directe
c'est extraordinaire on a là une vraie
une wii à une vraie démocratie qui se
met en place et c'est cela que nous
voulons au maximum voilà jtekt à côté de
chez nous les salariés se sont mis en
grève parce que justement augmentation
de la productivité dégradation des
conditions de travail
ils ont fait valoir leurs droits le
droit constitutionnel au droit de grève
tous ces salariés ont été sanctionnés
voilà aussi la réalité du dialogue
social dans les entreprises
alors et de la guerrero vous vos
attentes sur sur cette deuxième phase de
concertation qui va s'ouvrir dès jeudi
prochain
alors nous nous donnions nous n'ignorons
pas les évolutions du travail dans la
société nous regardons ça de très près
nous avons donc fait des positions
d'ailleurs lors de la conférence sociale
la leaf est fait les camarades qui
étaient à la conférence sociale ont fait
des propositions dans ce sens à
certaines tables rondes mais moi j'aurai
quand même revenir sur un petit peu la
version derrière schild énorme dans tous
les pc la clé dans tous les pays où il y
a eu inversion des archis des normes
peut citer deux exemples c'est l'espagne
et le portugal
le dialogue social s'est appauvrie d'une
façon extraordinaire
c'est comme ça monsieur kern ccd exemple
ces exemples on va pas prendre ces
exemples trop pour la france et je
terminerai en dire en disant tout
simplement la clé de cette histoire
c'est l'austérité menées depuis des
décennies qui est dangereuse
socialement économiquement et
démocratiquement et démocratiquement
aussi voilà notre message aujourd'hui à
force ouvrir alors le code du travail
nous attellerons si on nous consulte
nous irons et nous donnerons nos
positions on a déjà on a déjà des
propositions à faire sur le sujet il
barre vous avez dit dans cette émission
vous vous êtes contre l' inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes contrairement au
medef quelle est la solution pour vous
final pour que le peler les salariés qui
est un minimum de garanties tout de même
et pour que les employeurs puissent
embaucher des gens préalable j'aurais
j'aurais aimé qu avant d'être mis devant
un projet de loi on fasse travailler les
partenaires sociaux sur le sujet il
semblait légitime que les partenaires
sociaux sur le code du travail puisse
avoir un temps des changes et faire des
propositions
tous les gros au ministère avant que le
ministère nous explique comment il a
fait pour la version de la hiérarchie de
la discussion
lucho sur le dialogue et le dialogue
social et le paritarisme j'en suis à
faire un fervent défenseur
et franchement
on constate que c'est tout sauf du
dialogue au niveau 2 du ministère
on nous mais on nous amène des projets
en disant voilà c'est comme ça que ça se
passait avec une marge de négociation
très limité ce qui conduit assez souvent
à ce que le dialogue ne s'installe pas
puisque la place qu'elle essaie pour le
dialogue est tellement congrue qu' il
n'y a pas de place et ont dit après à
bâle paritarisme marche pas donc on va
légiférer et on va faire à votre place
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut prendre
les choses après pour répondre à votre
question je les dis je pense qu'il faut
effectivement revoir et simplifier un
certain nombre de choses dans le code du
travail ça c'est clair
après je reste sur ma position qu'il
faut renvoyer la négociation collective
vers la branche et non pas au niveau de
l'entreprise avec une refonte des
branches d'ailleurs qui est avec une
refonte des branches il y en a besoin il
y en a besoin également il ya ce qu'ils
sont devenus obsolètes je dirais en tout
cas qui n'ont plus de réalité dans le
monde économique d'aujourd'hui un
sentiment pour conclure chacun est ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'on va vers
une vraie réforme nécessaire ou est-ce
que ça va retomber un peu comme un comme
un soufflé vu les prises de position des
uns et des autres qui sont quand même
très divergent notamment au sein des
syndicats où il n'avait pas la même
position que la cellule était tout à
fait mais ceci dit je crois que au
niveau des accords d'entreprise y en a
beaucoup
on pourrait faire croire qu'il n'ya pas
d'accord d'entreprise 300 350 milles
accord en 2014 il ya des accords
d'entreprise bien évidemment alors qu'a
expliqué lâché j'ai alors pour vous il
faut pas changer alors le combat mais
non c'est pas le sujet c'est
qu'effectivement l'objet du gouvernement
c'est comme le veut le medef c'est faire
en sorte que l'accord d'entreprise face
loi et c'est ça le problème
parce que se passe-t-il un accord
national d'entreprises à la loi le code
du travail est garant de l'intérêt
général garande d'un droit à souk de
droit pour tous les salariés
le problème si on inverse tout dire que
on va se retrouver avec des droits des
salariés qu'ils seront pas les mêmes
selon la petite entreprise selon la
grosse entreprise selon le rapport de
force
faisons en sorte que et faisons tomber
ce que dit le medef comme quoi vous
rendez compte de notre dans notre pays
on fait croire aux salariés qu'il coûte
leur dit le coût du travail vous coûter
cher
et maintenant on leur dit vos
protections vos droits ça coûte
balayons besson vos salaires en enlever
vos protections et comme ça on va
embaucher vous rendez compte en pl
cueillis dans quel pays on est et ce
qu'on renvoie aux salariés que ce sont
eux par leur qualification leur
investissement qui créent les richesses
de ce pays
je crois que dans notre pays on peut
franchement dire voilà dans le cas d'un
développement économique
les salariés doivent avoir des droits ça
c'est le sens du progrès social
parce que faire croire que les salariés
avec - droit on va aller mieux
ça me kern c'était 19ème siècle c'était
le travail à la tâche c'était et
regarder en bas de la dèche
imaginez par exemple rapidement ses
salariés les salariés sans droits
uniquement dans les négociations
d'entreprise ça serait le top
les salariés du bangladesh ça serait le
top du top malheureusement ce n'est pas
le cas vous avez vu comme moi le rien
pizza alors je je je prône pas le
bangladesh va vous l'avez compris comme
une évidence chez vous mais l'amour est
ce qu'on va vers 3 est-ce qu'on va vers
l'est alors si elles se déroulent vite
c'est possible si elle se déroule
lentement
ça me paraît délicat parce que lille y
aura les présidentielles qui
enchaîneront et qui empêcheront le pays
bouger pendant à les six mois un an
en étant optimiste avant cette élection
je pense qu'il ya une vraie volonté
parce qu'aujourd'hui finalement si on
veut regarder le paysage
je veux pas vous agresser en disant cela
mais il ya guère que cgt et fo qui sont
contre ces évolutions
aujourd'hui tout le monde avait
conscience je vire même quand on regarde
tout le temps les cinq ans alors qu'elle
était de prescott activités alors oui
oui et non parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui fait qu'on veut
aller vers des accords d'entreprise
c'est peut-être que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui à un million cinq cent
mille syndiqués en france dont 1
millions qui proviennent de la fonction
publique à peu près donc les salariés
syndiqués qui première écoute et vous
c'est les chiffres que j'ai 500 milles
qui proviennent du secteur privé pour 18
millions de salariés s'étaient taris il
faudrait augmenter long de de syndiqués
pour que avoir des syndiqués dont toutes
les entreprises on pourrait faire des
accords dans toutes les entreprises en
intégrant les syndicats ne parlons que
vous êtes
patronale parce que vous n'êtes pas issu
des élections mais bien du nombre de
cotisations qui vous sont payés alors en
terme de représentativité sujet des
attaques puissantes d'ailleurs je crois
que le rapport propose qu'ils aient plus
de 50% des voix accord majoritaire
l'accord majoritaire
mais ça c'est une bonne chose je ne
comprends pas pourquoi la démocratie
fait peur mais d'amour mois l'accord
mais je m'en vais pas c'est pas ça ne
doit pas faire loi pour l'ensemble des
salariés en partant d'entreprise bon
allez il barre votre conclusion vous
avez l'impression que ça va faire
évoluer les choses pour les petites
entreprises que vous représentez ici
alors ça ferait évoluer les choses pour
les petites entreprises si enfin dans ce
pays on arrête de légiférer et de voir
les choses par le prisme des grandes
je reste sur ma brave n'est toujours que
97% des voix des salariés quand même 50
% des salariés quand même et 97 % des
entreprises rapidement
là aussi des entreprises sans salarié il
ya aussi optimiste non optimiste je
dirais qu'on verra à l'épreuve à
l'épreuve du texte de loi qui sera
opposé à adopter lorsque entre le projet
lé texte adopté il ya encore une marge
de modifications qui est tellement
grande et on l'a vu j'ai pas
l'impression que ce sera une très très
grande réforme
très franchement est révolu quand on
parle de simplification mois le monde
fait un peu peur parce que derrière très
souvent on va vers de la
complexification donc heure est au pied
du mur qu'on voit mais le mur comme
disait l'autre
gray moi j'attends beaucoup des
propositions va nous coûter des
propositions mais je dis jeudi pour
répondre à monsieur caire dans l'aide
il ya beaucoup d'accords dans les
entreprises énormément d'accord
d'ailleurs qui sont signés par des
organisations syndicales comme les faux
et comme la cgt plaisir de voir que cgt
et fo peu dans ce pays la démocratie s
exerce mais c'est à géométrie variable
il n'y a pas très longtemps il ya un
accord a été signé à l'open de paris par
un syndicat dont je tairai le nom qui
représentent 15% et des autres qui
représentent 90 % n'ont même pas eu le
droit au chapitre
voilà sur les rtt c'est aussi ça
mercredi un autre à simone rendez vous
en tout cas mercredi prochain pour
entendre les propositions de myriam el
khomri on arrive déjà d'autres termes de
cette émission merci en tout cas à tous
les quatre d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez voir ou revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet bourgogne point
france 3 point fr la semaine prochaine
nous vous donnons rendez vous pour le
premier des quatre débats que nous
consacrons le tout au long de ce mois de
novembre aux élections régionales des 6
et 13 décembre prochains
mais pour l'heure c'est le 12/13 qui se
poursuit avec le développement de
l'actualité nationale et internationale
très bel après-midi à tous merci
on